andrew is going to start us off in
california hey andrew how are you
dave i'm great how are you better than i
deserve sir how can i help
all right so uh i am
i'm on uh baby step
seven i'm investing now uh
21 years old i'm in the military so
living in a barracks room i have no
mortgage i have a roth ira open with
vanguard with twelve thousand dollars in
it
uh but it's in a money market account
and has been since i
started deployment uh
what should i invest in okay well good
good so you're in baby step seven
because you don't have a house right
exactly okay what's in baby set three
andrew real quick
what's your fully funded emergency fund
amount
uh i i just actually came back from
deployment with the uss nimitz
so i actually have uh yeah
you should have a lot i have a healthy i
have a healthy
little checking account how much is in
your healthy checking account
uh about thirty four thousand dollars
and another twelve in savings
good for you thank you for your service
sir we appreciate your service and thank
you
it's quite quite a uh an assignment
you've been given
and uh very very well done so what we
teach
is to invest in good mutual funds it's
what i have done
for 40 years and what anthony does and
what all of us here do
we invest in growth stock type mutual
funds
there are four categories and we split
it evenly across those and that's what
you need to get in touch with vanguard
and move into those four or get in touch
with one of our smart investor pros
to help you with that they are not
people that work for us but they're
people that we recommend that will do
things
and they will teach you which is really
important at your stage of investing for
you to start
learning because investing can be a
little bit intimidating can't it
oh for sure i was looking at uh looking
at
my account today and i was seeing a lot
of uh
terms that i didn't really recognize
yeah
cause i was i was looking at it uh one
that caught my attention was a
u.s growth stock with a 3 000 investment
minimum
uh i was thinking about going into that
one but
uh i didn't understand it so that's good
don't don't put money in something you
don't understand yeah and andrew i think
the key thing here what dave is saying
what i want to tell you as a young
person too
is um that i like the fact that you're
saying hey i don't understand this
well it's very important to remember
what dave said find a financial advisor
and i'll say this i mean i'm not a huge
fan of you know certain people i want
you to go to one of our smart vested
pros because they're going to spend time
with you
and teach you everything you need to
know i'm not going to speak negative
about vanguard but i'm pretty sure
they're not going to give you as much
one-on-one training as
our smart investors will and it's
important for you at your age to really
get the knowledge
while you're investing your money and so
ask the good questions
yeah the nervousness that you feel with
anything new
is wisdom like the first time you get
behind the wheel of a car you've never
driven a car it's
you're nervous the first time you do x
or why ride a bicycle whatever the
metaphor we want to use is so in fact
you don't know what you're doing is
it makes you nervous that's that's
wisdom but that that's also says you got
some learning
and the more you learn the more
comfortable you are
and it will become like driving a car
where initially you were nervous but
eventually you
develop a level of competency
and you learn the terms and you're very
comfortable with them the good news is
if you sit down with the smartvestor pro
with the heart of a teacher they're
going to teach you now let's start with
that
where you were a minute ago okay a
growth
stock mutual fund now what a mutual fund
is is think about anything as mutual as
a group of people
so a mutual fund is a group of people
funded to fund
and so you put some money in i put some
money in anthony put some money in right
it's a mutual fund mutually
funded that's where it comes from okay
that's a mutual fund okay
instead of buying a single stock
whatever they
invest that money that we mutually
funded
into tells us what kind of mutual fund
it is
and so if they invest that money into
bonds then it's a bond
mutual fund if they invest that money
into companies
stock ownership in that company and
these are companies that are growing
we would call those growth stocks
right and and if it's a mutual fund
it would be a growth stock mutual fund
in your case it was u.s which tells us
one more thing
where are all these companies andrew
the grand old united states of america
there you go baby
and so if it were an international fund
it would have
some it would have only funds that are
not
u.s companies that are not us
if it's a world fund
then it's the whole world so it's got
some u.s
some foreign in it but in your case
you're looking at american companies
only
that are growing and it's multiple
different companies 90 to 200 different
companies they'll be bought in there
and people mutually funded this fund
including you and so you own a piece of
a whole bunch of pieces of little bitty
pieces of
growth companies companies that are
growing and that will grow your money
like about 10 times as fast as a stupid
money market account you're in
so that's your first lesson dude this is
how you learn it
well done i'm proud of you and again
thank you for your service click
smartvestorpro at daveramsey.com
and we'll get you lined up